there's a disturbing trend of law
enforcement coming under attack outrage
sweeping the nation following the murder
of a 9 11 first responder in New York
City
24-year FDNY veteran Lieutenant Allison
Russo Elling was walking in uniform less
than a block from her station
house when she was stabbed over 20 times
in a quote barbaric and completely
unprovoked attack the suspect was taken
into custody after barricading himself
inside a nearby building he is charged
with murder and criminal possession of a
weapon NYPD commissioner kitchen Sewell
condemning the senseless attack
this deadly senseless broad daylight
attack on a uniformed EMT member is a
direct assault on our society
it is the latest consequence of the
violence that we relentlessly fight in
our city also in the Big Apple a man has
been charged after allegedly smashing
the windows and lights of an NYPD
cruiser with a metal pipe police
arresting him nearby Greg um this the
support EMT she was six months away from
retirement yeah it's incredible and you
know in the the read that you just did
you said outrage sweeping the nation I
wish that was true I kind of feel like
that's wistful thinking yeah we're just
numb to it it used to be one of these I
I said this before but one of these
outrageous grisly crimes could
completely reverse a downward spiral
into criminal Anarchy it would only take
one an innocent being knifed on the
subway but now the two things happening
they're happening with such kind of a
mundane uh pattern and activity that
we've gotten used to it and also the
media isn't interested in it like we're
doing it but we're in our world right I
don't think this is on I don't know I
shouldn't say this but I don't think
it's on MSNBC or CNN because I don't
watch them but it seems the media is too
interested in activism and racism and
pronouns and then they go and then when
they do their story they just go on
Twitter to see how clever they can be
this is this is a story that should be
Nationwide uh this woman survived 9 11
and she couldn't survive drive a trip to
the bodega because of that and this is
the other thing the crazy person aspect
of this is becoming this thing
with every story and it's almost like it
says well there's nothing we can do the
person's mentally ill or crazy yes there
is you can put them away and we have to
put them away what gets me is
we're told now this guy's schizophrenic
well great that means he might have been
unaware that what he did was horrific
then why did he run and hide clearly he
isn't that insane if he's you know if he
didn't stand by his work if he stood by
his work and said look what I did that's
crazy but he actually knew he did
something wrong so I think we have to we
have to rethink everything but I always
feel like when we do these stories we're
just speaking to clouds until we until
we say something that is truly shocking
and pierces through the bubble uh uh
into the uh so politicians actually give
an f right I almost said it but they
don't give an f until their damn job is
up they only care about the politics of
it they don't want to be seen as mean or
cruel to people in marginal populations
like the mentally ill or the drug
addicted or the homeless the people that
are committing a lot of these crimes
they don't want to you know they're
cowards they're complete cowards and
it's in I don't know just well words
people people will have a chance to talk
about this issue or at least with vote
at The Ballot Box in less than well a
little more than five weeks and Bill
Clinton the former president he weighed
in about crime and this election listen
here
you can't go around complaining that
people are violating Democratic norms
when the voters are rewarding them for
it
either by staying home
or being distracted by last minute scare
tactics
I mean we lost the last two weeks to the
2020 election on uh defund the police
and socialism
and that was our fault we shouldn't let
that happen Jesse what do you think of
that I listened to him when he talks
about crime because he grew up poor and
he was the governor of Arkansas when
you're the governor you come face to
face with these killers it's up to you
whether or not you say fry them or grant
clemency and as Governor he killed a lot
of really disgusting evil people and he
didn't want to do it he said he was
against the policy but he respected the
wishes of the people in Arkansas and
governors have a special role to play
and a lot of these people making these
decisions weren't Governors they didn't
get to see these people you know you get
a sheet this guy raped five kids this
guy knifed a woman in the back
you look at that of course you're going
to go yes execute the guy he understands
crime better than most Democrats
and then I looked into the crime
situation here now you basically have
two types of criminals you have your
traditional criminal that goes out and
prays on people and then you have your
dangerously mentally ill person and I
found out that in 1950 we had a half a
million people institutionalized you
know how many we have now 37 000. what
the hell happened it looks like in the
Civil Rights Movement where we granted
all these rights to the people that
didn't have rights at the time blacks
women workers the environment got more
rights to people with disabilities they
said hey let's bring the mentally ill
along too and let's give them all the
rights right and there's a phrase for
that it's called the term dying with
one's rights on which means you can be
mentally ill but you could be dying on
the street you can have all your rights
but hey you're going to be dead and
Naked and Afraid and disease ridden
because the country is not trying to
help you now the country was spending a
lot of money on these institutions so
they wanted to cut the budget and they
found out all these drugs I'm sure
you're familiar with some that you don't
need a psychiatrist watching you 24 7
you give the guy a pill and he's
lobotomized so they're just big Pharma
love that they give you pills and then
they just kind of make all of these
insane people go back and live with
their parents they put them in nursing
homes so that's what happened and now
you see people just running around
swinging at people and stabbing people
so the country has to look and say we
the pendulum swung way too far on the
left and now we have to get it to a
place where the compassionate response
is to institutionalize people
uh Jessica you grew up in this city um
and you also have your finger on the
pulse of what's Happening Across America
when this discussion about crime is
ongoing where do you see things for the
Democrats and Republicans five weeks
before on the issue of crime and how
will it play
obviously become an issue of huge
importance in races if you look at
what's gone on in Wisconsin with Mandela
Barnes and Ron Johnson it swung back to
Ron Johnson that is purely on what's
going on in terms of attacking Mandela
barns on the issue of crime featuring in
the John fetterman race as well I know
we've been talking about that all week
and Democrats are afraid of it the
Chester Boudin recall in San Francisco
that was pushed forward by Asian
Democrats actually who were sick of what
was going on the hate crimes against
them in their City perpetrated mostly by
black people and so this is the number
one concern I would say
um on a political issue level for
Democrats obviously the economy will be
the number one issue but this is
something that we can actually say
something about and I think Bill Clinton
you know he's proven that he's really
pressing about these things and he
understands how to win elections 2016
would have been different I think if
they'd listened to him I want to return
to what Greg was saying at the beginning
about a story like this you just shut
down the news cycle and I was thinking
about the two police officers who were
murdered in their car
no no
um during the de Blasio years yeah and
that during the funeral the police
officers turned their backs on the mayor
of New York City
and that felt like a crescendo moment
right certainly for our city but for
other major cities across the country
where it said this cannot stand we
cannot have policies and an attitude
towards police that leaves us vulnerable
to these kinds of attacks and that was
one attack
and I think that there's obviously the
conversation about what laws we have in
place that people know they're not going
to jail or they'll be out in 10 minutes
because of you know the bail laws Etc
but there's a Brokenness in humanity
right now that is truly frightening to
me when you the attack on the mother of
five at JFK for instance that is not
about I know I'm going to be out you
know because Alvin Bragg you know won't
hold me there that guy I had no idea
what the laws were going to look like he
had no respect for human life he just
wanted to destroy her to destroy her for
absolutely no reason and that isn't just
about institutionalizing people
um or laws there is a culture of
disrespect for The Human Condition that
is so fundamentally disturbing to me and
politics doesn't fix that that's bigger
than politics digging well that's true
they're like there's a longer term issue
but there's also the short-term
immediate issue which is we have a lot
of mentally unstable people in a lot of
these cities all across the country and
they are committing random acts of
violence that are sometimes leading to
Deaths but also just ruining people's
lives altogether I think the culture the
cultural problem isn't of disrespect
it's of ignoring the seriously mentally
ill the dangerous mentally ill they
violently psychotic we talk about you
talk about it you talk about it Jesse
but when the media Witnesses a crime
that they can big media politicians you
know the professional clatterbags when
they see a something violent that they
can use to their benefit it's a hate
crime it's an anti-asian crime it's not
a psychotic crime a crime of psychosis a
mass shooting weeks will be spent
picking apart somebody's political
beliefs are they Mega racist talking
about getting guns out of people's hands
gun restrictions gun bans or gun
freedoms rather than talking about the
mentally ill person who committed the
crime why was that individual on the
street today uh we need to talk about
how the seriously mentally ill could be
supervised they're more than 97 few
percent fewer beds than there were in
1955. that were the number of hospital
beds for the mentally ill down almost
100 percent they're almost down to
nothing how can people be medicated and
how can the public be protected from
these individuals because right now the
new mental institution is the prison or
the jail and we need to destigmatize
mental illness acknowledge that homeless
people aren't homeless because rents are
too high because property is too high
it's because they're sick and rather
than pretending like it's something
thing else other than they need to be in
a hospital and locked up rather than on
the street and just one more thing as
proof of that if you go through the list
of people who've been assaulted in New
York Michelle go pushed onto the subway
tracks mentally ill person Daniel
Enriquez shot on the Q train worked at
Goldman Sachs mentally ill person and
Peter zazopoulos who killed Allison
Russo the lieutenant she he was
transported to the hospital by her unit
wow in 2018 for making
anti-asian online
threats he was taken to the hospital
probably committed for 72 hours but
right back out on the street to kill her
you need they need to be locked up and
medicated and so the entire public is
safe hey Sean Hannity here hey click
here to subscribe to Fox News YouTube
page and catch our hottest interviews
and most compelling analysis you will
not get it anywhere else